there's so many new Beauty releases
happening all the time so we gathered
some of the most hyped products to test
for ourselves I've never tried a product
from Jane Iredale before but this one
intrigued me this is the hydropure
tinted serum it's a Serum with a bunch
of pigment beads inside that are meant
to give you light coverage you're
supposed to mix this with your fingers
first to break up the beads then apply
with your fingers I really don't like
finger applications for foundations but
it really was the best way to apply this
product it did not look great when I
tried it with a brush in my sponge the
coverage is definitely light I feel like
it looked like I had no makeup on at all
I was hoping it would feel moisturizing
but it felt like nothing on my skin all
my other makeup went on top of this just
fine and I really liked how my skin was
looking it's so expensive but I think
this is great for people who want a very
natural looking skin tint Charlotte
Tilbury released these hypnotizing pop
shots single Shadows the packaging on
this is so cute this is meant to be a
super glittery pigmented
multi-dimensional shadow so this was
really easy to apply I just swiped it on
with my finger and Blended out the edges
I did get a tiny bit of Fallout but I
was able to just brush it away I really
love the sparkly Shifty effect you get
with this formula you can definitely get
a similar effect with one of those
colourpop super shock Shadows but this
formula is really beautiful on the eyes
rare Beauty just released a powder
version of its super popular
highlighters I've been seeing some
conflicting statements about whether
this product looks glittery there is
definitely some super fine glitter in
this formula but I don't think it looks
glittery on the skin the glow is
obviously there and it's so pretty it's
almost wet looking I actually thought it
emphasized my texture a bit when I first
tried it when I tried it the second time
I just went in with a little less
product and it looked better I don't
think this is as natural looking as the
liquid version but it's still a really
nice highlighter I tried a couple new
Fenty products this month the plush
puddin intensive recovery lip mask and
the glossy Posse volume 5.0 let's talk
about the lip mask first the packaging
is really cool you twist it and the
product dispenses from the top so you
don't have to dip into it the formula is
very thick which I personally love it
just feels so moisturizing and plush on
the lips it also gave this really nice
shine I wasn't expecting I did wear the
slip mask for a couple nights to see if
it helped with my dryness and I saw the
difference my lips were so much more
soft and hydrated so I am definitely
going to keep using this now onto the
glossy Posse volume 5.0 Fenty Beauty
does these gloss sets for the holiday
season every year usually with a limited
edition shade inside this set contains a
gloss bomb cream in cupcake in a gloss
bomb heat and Fenty glow heat and a
regular gloss bomb in fuchsia Flex
cupcakin is a really pigmented gloss and
Fenty glow heat gives you that kind of
spicy tingly lip Plumping fuchsia Flex
is the specific Shade that's been going
viral it's fenty's regular gloss formula
in this really beautiful deep pink that
has a ton of glitter in it all of these
formulas feels so good on the lips Fenty
does not mess with its gloss formula
people have been raving about the kosas
revealer concealer forever so I finally
got it it's supposed to be medium
coverage and super creamy this concealer
was easy to work with and Blended out so
quickly and easily the coverage looked a
bit lighter than medium to me but it
covered enough I would go in with a
little more next time but I loved how
this looked I also got the cloud set
setting powder which people also really
love I used my puff to apply this and it
smoothed everything out almost instantly
I was so impressed by this powder and I
usually hate pressed powders I never use
them let alone to set my concealer but
this looked so nice I used it on the
rest of my face too and it just gave
this really soft blurred look it
mattified but not too much I loved these
two products especially together this is
The Hourglass Cosmetics Phantom
volumizing glossy balm it's supposed to
be a lip balm lip plumper and a lip
gloss all in one product these applied
nicely but because this formula is so
fragile it's easy to apply too much I
had to smooth the product out with my
finger a couple times but other than
that I loved these they have this really
nice cooling effect they do feel like a
super moisturizing lip balm and they
have this High shine finish like a gloss
it didn't do much for me in terms of
Plumping so I think if that's the main
thing you want from a lip product don't
get this one I did a little haul at elf
and I got some new products and some
products I've been wanting to try first
up is this elf luminous putty bronzer
this goes from a putty formula to a
powder up close you can see a lot of
Shimmer in this but it doesn't look that
way on the skin this is one of the most
blendable bronzers I've ever tried like
it takes no time at all to blend this
out and it brings a really natural
warmth to the skin this was so good next
I tried the Halo glow Powder Puff which
is always out of stock people love this
I thought it wasn't going to be any
different to my normal powder Puffs but
it is it's much thicker and softer than
these cheap ones I buy it does pick up a
lot of product but I just evened it out
on the back of my hand this did such a
nice job of applying my powder next I I
tried the Lash and roll mascara which
kind of reminds me of the benefit roller
lash I usually hate silicone brush
mascaras but I actually like how this
one applied the product it felt like it
got every single lash my lashes are so
straight but this gave them a nice curl
I wish it thickened my lashes more but
for six bucks this is a really good
drugstore mascara the last product I
tested was the glossy lip stain I can't
believe I've never tried these before
this formula is so interesting it feels
like water on the lips like hydrating
but also weightless these are a bit
patchy there were some areas where it
looked like the product wasn't sticking
after letting the product sit for a few
minutes I removed it and it definitely
did leave a stain behind but the stain
also looked patchy I do like how this
formula feels on the lips but it doesn't
apply evenly for the most part though
this was a pretty good haul
foreign
[Music]